you know I got to say admittedly I am a
pretty nervous and paranoid flyer well
I'm a nervous paranoid person in general
but especially when I'm flying I happen
to be that way so and I was flying down
to Texas yesterday to speak at an event
down here and so you can imagine my
reaction when as we are flying there we
hit a little bit of turbulence and then
the captain comes on the the intercom
and he makes an announcement and you
know it's it's all right it's it's a
problem for me that for whatever reason
when when airline captains give
announcements they they always mumble
and they make no attempt to actually be
heard when you know this is this is this
is one announcement I want to hear like
you're the person who's behind the
mysterious door who's piloting this tin
box 500 miles per hour over the clouds
our lives are in your hands I want to
know what you're saying so please
enunciate but anyway so he's on there
mumbling I can understand what he's
saying I the only thing I could pick up
I picked up two phrases he taught he
spokes about 45 seconds I pick up two
phrases I heard him say pretty chaotic
and then a few seconds later he said
isn't working okay so I knew I didn't
know what else was going on all I knew
is that something is chaotic which isn't
good and something isn't working and I
had no idea what it is and then I
started I look around and no one else is
reacting to this like no one else is
concerned that there is dysfunction and
and chaos that has me that is apparently
made its way on to this plane no one
else is worried about it anyway we made
it home we made it there in one piece
but it was I just look if you're gonna
if you're gonna use phrases like that in
words like that as a as an airline pilot
just make sure we can hear everything
you're saying in context I still don't
know what was chaotic I is it'll be a
mystery until the day I die all right um
so speaking of chaotic the Democratic
primary race I do want to you know
briefly talk about this Joe Biden of
course entered the race yesterday so we
all can rejoice Biden
Biden who first became a senator in 1973
that's 46 years ago he's held political
office continuously over that entire
time except for the last two years and
now he wants to be President he's and I
think I think that's enough reason to
reject him there are other reasons too
all the other stuff bad policies the
creepiness you know all that kind of
stuff but that doesn't even need to
enter into the conversation the fact is
that Biden is an almost 77 year old man
who's had his hands on the reins of
power for for half a century and I think
we just say you know that's enough Joe
let someone else take a turn how about
that why don't you let someone else get
a shot at this thing it's 50 years by
about 50 years that's enough time you
don't need you don't really don't need
to go beyond that so that's I think
that's kind of all you need to know
about him and I'm not gonna go into the
whole I'm not gonna get into a lot of
inside baseball analysis of Joe's
campaign rollout and his prospects and
everything mostly because I don't care
that much but I will say that I will say
just a couple of brief things number one
President Trump really needs to up his
his nicknaming game because it's fallen
off I think sharply over the last year
and that's a pretty concerning
development especially when his whole
pretty much his whole strategy Trump's
whole strategy against his opponent is
just a nickname them so if that if
you're gonna if you're gonna put all
your eggs in that basket you better
really come with with the big guns which
he did in 2016 but I I don't know
recently I've so he's going with sleepy
Joe that's his nickname for Joe Biden
now I I like that nickname
I like the sound of it it kind of sounds
like maybe the sort of nickname that a
mediocre baseball player might have
earned in 1912
you know the shortstop of the the
Yankees in the early 20th century sleepy
Joe that's all sleepy Joe over there but
it doesn't work for Biden because Biden
isn't known for sloth necessarily he's
not known for being sleepy or low energy
it's not really it's just it's not gonna
it's not gonna click because that's not
what we know him for
yeah he's old but so is Trump I mean
they're close enough in age to have
attended the same high school that you
know at the same time basically that's
so close back in the 14th century so
sleepy Jo doesn't work creepy Jo is much
better you're going with sleepy Jo
meanwhile you've got creepy Jo just
there for the taking
much more on brand much more devastating
much more embarrassing for for Joe Biden
I mean it really it seems like Trump's
nicknames have gotten sleepy ironically
enough now in terms of of Biden's
prospects you know in the general
election I think his prospects are
pretty good I did the latest poll had
him up by like 8 points over Trump you
decide whether to trust that poll or not
but I don't think Trump has to worry
about it because even if he's polling
over Trump he's not gonna make it
through the Democratic nomination
process he's not gonna be nominated the
fact is the Democrat Party has gone so
far left so fast that they've they've
they've left they've escaped Earth's
gravity at this point and they're
hovering somewhere over Europa or
something like that despite what the
polls may say I don't I don't think that
a guy like Joe Biden old and white and
vaguely centrist has a chance of winning
the nomination in the modern Democratic
Party I think a person like that could
win in the general in a landslide
potentially but he couldn't make it
through the gauntlet of the Democratic
nomination process in the first place in
order to get to that point because he's
going to be eaten alive and we're going
to see that play out over the next few
weeks here is I think in my opinion
here's let me describe a candidate who
could win 75 million votes in this
country I think this will be a candidate
who is pro-abortion up until only up
until 20 weeks Pro gay marriage
Pro welfare non interventionist
pro-gun appro immigration enforcement
Pro free speech critic of police
brutality and police excesses not
perceived as racist but also not an sjw
okay now I would not vote for such a
candidate because I disagree with a
number of the positions I just outlined
there so I'm not I'm not saying that
this is a candidate I want to vote for
I'm saying that I think that is where
America is right now that they would go
for someone like that that combination
of positions would actually stand a
chance of attracting sizable numbers of
people from both sides from both parties
and it is it's more of a leftist more
liberal platform and it's it's you know
if any party is going to put forward a
candidate with that selection of
positions on the issues then it would be
the Democrats but they just they're not
going to do it anymore
basically what I just described that's
that is essentially Bill Clinton in 1992
I guess now he pretended to be against
gay marriage at that point but for the
most part that is what the Democrat
Party was 30 years ago and I think that
party in 2019 against Donald Trump would
be formidable but the modern iteration
of the Democrat Party is a totally
different thing because parties changed
dramatically since then it's changed
it's changed so much if that's if you've
been paying attention over the last week
a number of Democratic candidates were
asked this week if they think the
government should provide a third option
for gender on on government forms and
stuff and of course several of the
candidates will all of the candidates
who were asked this question said yes
Camilla Harris said yes now do you think
that Camilla Harris really believes that
there are three genders or 100 genders
or whatever the left is sag now do you
think she really takes his transgender
stuff seriously
no I she she certainly
doesn't and we know all of these
Democrats almost all the Democrats who
are running they don't really take this
and I know that because most of them
were on the political scene 10 years ago
and they weren't talking about this
stuff back then this is just where the
base has dragged them to where they have
to pretend Kamala Harris in particular
she's kind of an interesting case
because she's she I think in her heart
of hearts she's a little bit of a
law-and-order
reactionary even now she wasn't
interested in law and order in
California when it came time to
prosecute Planned Parenthood for for for
selling baby parts because she is a
minion of the abortion industry as all
Democrats are but aside from that she's
not exactly naturally a squish when it
comes to law and order stuff yet she has
to temper that or stifle it completely
pretend it doesn't exist and effect this
impression of a social justice warrior
and you know LGBT trans Ally and all
that kind of stuff it doesn't come
naturally to her it doesn't seem like
and you could tell that she was she was
asked at a town hall a few days ago CNN
she was asked if she agrees with Bernie
Sanders about letting felons vote in
prison and her first answer was yeah
well that's a conversation we could have
we can have that discussion which is the
answer I give my kids when they asked if
we can go for ice cream or something
later I'll say oh yeah well we'll talk
about that I'll think about it well
that's a discussion we can have and the
answer is no but that was her tentative
kind of answer trying to get around it
and then the next day she was asked
again and she let her true colors come
through and she said now you know I'm a
prosecutor and never mind I I know I
don't think these scumbags should be
able to vote I'm paraphrasing she didn't
say scumbags but that was the point she
was trying to get across so she doesn't
do a very good job in pretending to be
in SJW Biden will be even less effective
pretending to
pink-haired feminist I mean Elizabeth
Warren actually is a pink-haired
feminist and even she comes off
awkwardly when she tries to portray
yourself that way the the party's going
so far left that even Elizabeth Warren
is trying to catch up and so what that
means is a guy like Joe Biden even
though I really think he could win in
the general election especially if he
ran on his real position what he really
believes not what he thinks the liberal
base wants him to say that person could
win but he's not gonna make it there
because of where the party is okay
speaking of crazy left-wing deranged
lunacy I'm gonna show you this and it's
disturbing I should warn you it's not
appropriate for children so if you've
got if you're watching the video right
now you've got kids in the room then you
know I make them leave the room for a
minute because it's it's as I said
disturbing all right now here's a
screenshot that came up on my Twitter
feed yesterday
take a look at this all right there it
is
this is and if you're if you're
listening on soundcloud or something it
is an image of a burlesque performer in
lingerie with a bunch of dollar bills
protruding out of her underwear and a
young girl looks to be maybe about eight
or nine years old putting money into
stuffing money into her underwear while
in the background you see adults at
least one of which would be the girl's
parents mother looking on approvingly
and smiling and applauding and filming
it on their phone that's the picture and
this is from this is an image from what
I could gather if you look at the the
the caption some kind of event some
children including or children targeting
events put on by Bella blue
entertainment a burlesque it says in the
caption brunch apparently for kids to
four to go to
it was shared on Facebook by this
company proudly so they were they were
bragging about it but they took it down
after the backlash yet defended it in a
follow-up post which was also taken down
as a matter of fact let me read the
caption to you on this picture it says
from Bella Blu entertainment it says
this little girl was at a brunch was at
brunch a few weeks ago and her family
was encouraging her to tip and engage
with me
it's always so refreshing to see
families actively D stigmatizing and
changing narratives around bodies and
sexuality at the end her mom came up to
me and said thank you for showing her
that being a strong woman is okay and I
told her no no thank you for exposing
her to burlesque and for encouraging her
to experiencing experience it so there
you go
thank you for exposing her to burlesque
because that's something that we all
need our young sons and daughters to be
exposed to I share that why am i sharing
this extremely disturbing picture and
story with you well because for one
thing I think the sexual abuse of a
child carried out in public should
provoke a reaction from us it's the kind
of thing that we should react to it's
news it's it's a story right I don't
ever want to get to the point where I
see something like that and I think oh
that again well whatever what are you
gonna do if we have lost our ability to
be outraged really outraged over stuff
like this then we've lost our humanity
we've lost everything
we've lost our spine we've lost our soul
outrage gets a bad rap these days and
for good reason because people get
outraged over stupid things all the time
so we get tired of hearing about people
being outraged but some things should
cause outrage there are things that
should provoke that in us and this is
one of them how do you think people
would have reacted fifty
years ago - a picture like this I I
think the reaction would have been
fairly nuclear as well it should be
children are now being groomed for
sexual abuse right in front of our eyes
these there are events officially
organized for that purpose for grooming
children whether it's whether it's this
or a drag queen story our or a drag
brunch I mean they they love to do the
brunch thing apparently is is a big is a
big thing now with degenerates who want
to groom children for sexual abuse all
of the worrying that conservatives did
about the potential normalization of
pedophilia down the road well here we
are we're down the road we got there we
arrived right it's happening right now
that's what this is it's the
normalization of pedophilia and in fact
I should brat back up because I called
this grooming for sexual abuse I said
that they're well they're grooming this
girl no they're not grooming her for
sexual abuse this is sexual abuse the
grooming already happened that that
phase is over now it's now she's
actually being abused this is the thing
itself happening to bring your child to
a burlesque show and have her stuffing
tips into a grown woman's underwear that
is sexual abuse and the people
responsible for it should be in prison
everyone in that picture except for the
child should be in prison maybe first
throw them in the stocks for a few days
let people go by that let that let the
town's folk go by and toss rotten eggs
and tomatoes at their faces and then and
then lock them in a jail cell for a few
years and let them think about it that's
the way it should go that's that's the
way it would be in a healthy society but
we don't live in a healthy society so
what happens is you we see stuff like
this and there are people who actually
click like and send supportive comments
and then everyone else kind of yawns or
rolls their eyes and says oh it's just
the way things are now yeah it may be
the way things are now but
it shouldn't be and we cannot accept
that I can't accept it we we can't throw
up our hands and say alright yeah so
kids get sexually abused on camera and
it's posted on social media alright
that's our country no this is the words
that they're any word you used to
condemn it is not going to be a harsh
enough word alright one more item to
cover John William King aged 44 I
believe was executed in Texas yesterday
King is one in a group the ringleader of
the group who kidnapped a man named
James Byrd Jr a black man tied him to
the back of their pickup truck dragged
him to death over the course of three
miles and they did this for explicitly
racist reasons the crime happened about
20 years ago King tried to get a
reprieve before the execution much like
I'm sure Byrd begged for a reprieve from
his execution but just as Byrd was not
granted that neither was King and he was
executed by lethal injection and now he
will be buried in a in a grave with a
tombstone that has no name just his
inmate number and that's how he will be
remembered or rather forgotten by
history as well it should be I bring up
this case because it's cases like this
not necessarily this specific case
because I've been going through this
transformation over a period of months
but these kinds of cases have caused me
to change my thinking on the death
penalty my thinking has evolved on the
subject and I wanted to tell you about
that I've been I've been for and against
the practice at various times most
recently against it and I was against it
pretty firmly for several years but more
recently I decided that I can't justify
a blanket opposition
to capital punishment crimes like this
it seems to me simply cry out for the
ultimate punishment there are things a
person can do which once having done
them cancels out their right to continue
existing and when I say that I realize
the implications of a statement like
that because I have often said that the
right to life is absolute
I've said everyone has the right to life
if you can't you can't lose it it's it's
ingrained it's absolute I have made
points like that in service to the pro
life case and the when arguing against
abortion but I've realized that I'm that
that's not the right way of framing it
it's not exactly true it's it's an
imprecise way of framing the pro-life
argument because your right to life is
of course not absolute you can lose it
and there are scenarios where we would
all agree that you lose your right to
life if you run in to my house with a
gun I am under no obligation to respect
your right to existence your right to
life I that right is null and void in
that situation as far as I'm concerned
you have forfeited it you forfeit it the
moment you come through my door wishing
to do me harm it would also be hard to
argue that enemy combatants on the
battlefield have an absolute right to
exist because if they did we couldn't
justify any act of war against them and
that would be ridiculous of course
maybe it's better to say that human
dignity is inherent is absolute and that
I certainly believe that inherent human
dignity is is naturally attended by a
right to life a right to exist but
though you cannot lose your inherent
dignity and therefore even the condemned
have a right to a humane execution you
can lose that attending right to life
now babies have not lost it and could
not lost it because lose it because they
are they are innocent they haven't done
anyone any harm there's no such thing as
an abortion in self-defense there's no
such thing as a punitive abortion these
are human beings who do have a right to
life certainly because they could not
possibly have done anything to lose it
but as I said the person running into
your house with a gun
can lose it and does the enemy soldier
on the battlefield can and does lose it
the question is whether a man who ties
another man to the back of a truck and
drags him until his body falls into
pieces the question is whether or not
that man can also and does also lose his
right to life and I would say yes there
is no place in human society for such a
person not even in prison there is just
no place for them by their own choice
they have chosen to forfeit their place
their claim on existence and if they and
if they want to forfeit that claim and
they express their forfeiture by killing
the innocent then we have no choice but
to respect their choice and abide by it
and say ok you don't want to be a
civilized human being who lives in human
society have it your way you you have
forced our hand
now that strikes me as as just it
strikes me as fair and it also is
important to me that and I feel much
more comfortable supporting the death
penalty now than I would have say 40
years ago because now we have DNA we can
do DNA evidence there is video
surveillance everywhere GPS technology
all of these things that make it
theoretically very possible to establish
beyond any doubt whatsoever that a
person did commit the crime they're
accused of I think one of the more
powerful arguments against the death
penalty is well what if you execute the
wrong man and that is a powerful
argument but it is also possible
especially with all this modern
technology to be absolutely sure that
you have the right man and if you're not
absolutely sure then
they shouldn't be in the execution
chamber they probably shouldn't even be
in a jail cell in that case so I think
the question comes down to this really
what is the point of the justice system
what's the point of laws and and trials
and all of that now some will say that
the point is segregation we have to
segregate dangerous people from the
innocent some will say that the point is
rehabilitation some say the point is
deterrent some say the point is
punishment I think that the answer is
all of the above I would choose all four
of these theories I think anyone in
prison should be there for at least one
of those reasons if not all four and if
none of the four apply then that is
probably someone who shouldn't be in
prison that's why I think you could make
the argument that nonviolent drug
offenders should not be in prison
because they aren't necessarily a threat
to society so segregation isn't
necessary
you're not going to rehabilitate drug
abusers by putting them in jail cells
that doesn't work jail is does not
appear to be an effective deterrent
against drug use and a person who does
destructive things to themselves
experiences the punishment for those
actions in the action itself and in the
natural consequences I don't really
think a heroin addict is has destroyed
their life their health everything I
don't think you need to add extra
punishments on top of that so crimes
that don't fit in it under any of those
umbrellas those are people who probably
shouldn't be in prison at all capital
punishment I would say fits under three
of those theories it's it permanently
segregates be dangerous people from
society it does present some kind of
deterrent to crime and most importantly
it exacts the ultimate punishment for
the ultimate transgression it is just
fitting I think it fits the crime the
crime necessitates it
I think in the end that is the simplest
argument for for capital punishment it's
the most kind of visceral argument and I
think it's the best and most powerful
that some crimes just warrant it and
that's all there is to it I'll tell you
one other thing about this because I am
I still am I can see the other side the
anti-death-penalty side I'll tell you
the one thing that still holds me back a
little bit from becoming a full on death
penalty advocate and this may seem like
a small thing but it's really not it's a
serious consideration and it's one that
I think we don't usually talk about or
take into consideration I am concerned
about the the psychological moral and
spiritual effect that the death penalty
has on those who are tasked with
administering it you could perhaps make
an argument that executing another man
is a job that nobody on earth is really
emotionally or spiritually equipped to
perform or handle that's an argument
that I hardly hear anyone ever make
against the death penalty but I think
it's a powerful argument I think about
the first scene of a documentary called
into the abyss by Werner Herzog it's an
anti-death penalty documentary very
compelling I think well done the very
first scene is an interview with a Texas
prison chaplain who attends executions
and prays over the condemned and he'll
even stand in the room while the
execution is happening if he's requested
and he'll put his hand on the inmates
ankle while the while he's being
executed now in the interview he doesn't
rail against the death penalty he
doesn't he doesn't give his opinion
about it at all he looked at it like
okay this is happening it's legal it's
and it's my duty to be there and bring
solace and hopefully some spiritual
enlightenment too to the condemned which
I think is
heroic and much-needed vocation but in
this interview just a few minutes long
you can see in this man's eyes and in
his body language and in his words you
see what sort of toll all of this
constant death and destruction and
misery has done to him
taken on him at one point he he starts
recounting this light-hearted story of
when he one time when he went went
golfing and he was on his golf cart and
I cut two little squirrels were playing
and they they darted in front of his
golf cart and he stopped suddenly before
he ran them over and it starts like a
light-hearted antidote but antidote but
then he anecdote but then he gets
emotional and he starting starts crying
about as he's telling this story and he
says you know life is precious I
couldn't I can't preserve the life of
the condemned men but I could preserve
this squirrels life so this was a man so
broken so beaten by all the death and
misery that his ability to simply save
one little squirrel or two little
squirrels from an early demise was
something that he that he grabbed on to
desperately and he cherishes even to
this day that one little glimmer of hope
and life meant so much to this guy
because he's surrounded by death all the
time and I found that to be powerful can
we as a society support an institution
that does that to people now we know
what it does to the person being
executed it kills them okay but what
about what it does to the people who are
whose Duty it is to be involved and to
carry these things out
can we ask anyone to perform those
duties or are those duties that again
nobody is fit for or equipped for or
prepared for
I don't know that's that's my one
sticking point I think it's a big one
even though no one really ever raises
that point but it is uh it's a difficult
one I guess maybe I'm not as convinced
as I originally thought as I as I kept
talking I convinced myself back in the
other direction so I don't know my I
guess I could still see it from both
sides so that was my house my long and
windy way to get back to the starting
point I guess which is I still don't
know how I feel about the death penalty
all right Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com is the
email address let's check some of your
emails this is from JL says hi Matt I
was listening to your show I heard you
say that there was no good reason to go
to college and I've heard but I've heard
of a very good one first I want to make
something clear I agree with you I know
people who went to college after school
and are losers now I also know people
who enlisted in the military and are now
a great officer is making a good living
but one argument that I've heard for
going to college right after school is
that you may meet a girl get married and
have kids then need to stay in a
low-paying job and not have time to go
to college how do you reconcile this
with your belief that you should get
married young which I also agree with
well sorry this was from Joey by the way
not JL jails the next guy Joey first of
all I don't I I certainly never said
that there's no good reason to go to
college there are many good reasons to
go to college I'm am NOT I would never
make a blanket statement like that I
think there there are many good reasons
to go to college my only point is you
should know what your reason is before
you go that's all I'm saying that's my
whole point
figure out what have a plan in mind and
I think for most people that is going to
mean not going to college right away
going into the workforce earning some
money gaining life experience and
maturity figuring out what it is you're
good at what you want to do what your
vocation is what your skills are and
then make your decision about going to
college or not that's my my main point
there as far as meeting someone are
getting married I guess I don't follow
your point exactly
you I mean you could meet someone at
college you can meet them not at college
I guess what you're saying that my whole
idea of going to college later might not
work because what if you get married
first and then it's difficult to go back
to college
yeah look a lot of different things can
happen but these are the kinds of
considerations that have led people to
the conclusion that well you've got a
rush out of high school and rush right
into college right away and kind of get
that out of the way because you'll never
be able to do it later and that's that's
not true I could go to college right now
if I wanted to especially these days
when you got online colleges everywhere
I've got three kids I've got three kids
a fourth on the way I could go to
college if I wanted to if I wanted to
take some classes go online and it might
take me a while to finish at all but I
could do that anyone could so that's why
you you have to figure out what your
path is going to be and then and then
follow it all right now this is from JL
says hi Matt love the show more
importantly the dense beard you sport
don't ever shave it because your voice
might have send a few octaves higher
that's why I never would I agree that is
my concern
anyway I read an article from the New
York Times today an opinion piece which
was an interview with serene Jones the
president of the Union Theological
Seminary I was pretty shocked how she
denied that the resurrection happened
and called the virgin birth a bizarre
claim and also proceeded to say I don't
worship an all-powerful all-controlling
omnipotent omniscient being I just
wondered if you had any thoughts on this
I'm a very active member of my faith and
want to thank you for how you explaining
your positions on things yeah well this
is the trend that's been happening in
Christianity really since the 18th
century and places like Union
Theological Seminary which is not a
seminary at all really but a hive of
heresy they've been at the forefront of
this naturalizing of Christianity I
didn't read the interview that you
mentioned but I can already tell that
this person is an atheist who maintains
some emotional connection to our
Christian past and therefore wants to
mine it for
for some moral lessons she's digging
through it to see what she can salvage
and that's all that she and her ilk
think that Christianity is good for it's
a source of moral lessons nice stories
that impart little tidbits of wisdom
like hey stops fables or basically a
fortune cookie but this is not
Christianity of course Christianity is
the belief in and worship of precisely
that all-powerful and omnipotent being
who she rejected a being who we believe
sent His only begotten Son to save
mankind from their sin if you don't
believe that then you aren't Christian
that is what Christianity is the word
Christ is in the word Christian it's
right there Christ is a supernatural
concept there's no such thing as a
naturalistic rationalistic
non-supernatural Christ concept so it's
right there in the name you got to
believe in Christ as Christ to be a
Christian if you reject that premise if
you reject the supernatural then holding
on to Christianity and scriptures for
just moral lessons is not only pointless
but impossible now it's pointless
because you don't you don't need it for
that then if you're not worried about
the supernatural aspect the afterlife
judgments in all of that then go then go
ahead and get your morality from a
fortune cookie you might as well and
then you also get it you get to eat a
cookie at the end of it so it's it's a
bonus but it's also impossible really to
reject the supernatural and then try to
find something else
in Christianity because from the
naturalist viewpoint we really have no
idea what Jesus said if he said any of
the things he's claimed to have said we
have no idea from the naturalistic
viewpoint now we as Christians believe
that the Holy Spirit guided the sacred
authors but if the Holy Spirit didn't
guide them because the Holy Spirit
doesn't exist which apparently this
person thinks the Holy Spirit doesn't
exist then that means that these are
guys were guys try
to record entire monologues and complex
theological exchanges from memory 40 or
50 or even 60 years after the fact with
the Holy Spirit sure they could do that
but on their own no by the naturalistic
logic there is no way we can be sure
that anything in the Bible actually
happened or that any of the words
recorded were actually spoken by the
person claimed to have spoken them and
so when you when you chop the
supernatural legs out from under the
Bible you're left with nothing you're
left with a jumble of words and stories
and you can't make heads or tails of it
and in that case why I run a seminary
even a fake seminary why bother with any
of this why why bother calling yourself
a Christian why not go and be a Buddhist
or something instead that's what makes
no sense to me so you have to for for
many reasons you have to accept the
supernatural aspects of the Christian
faith and be a Christian or reject them
and and don't be a Christian those are
the two fundamental options you have all
right this is from Taylor says my name
is Taylor a longtime viewer of the show
I'm a devout Episcopalian in Ohio I
recently had a meeting with the Church's
Council of elected officials called the
vestry in the meeting and preparation
for the bishops visit the Reverend
brought up not using the masculine
pronoun for God and instead of you
instead using gender-neutral pronouns
not only has my church adopted in SJW
perspective to the Bible but there is
also a socialist group that meets in the
chapel the very people who wish to
destroy us need our help
to plot our demise is there any way I
can reason with the Church Council to
bring back the more traditional aspects
of the church or is it a lost cause
Taylor I'm afraid to say and I hate to
be the bringer of bad news here but it
is it is a lost cause it's definitely a
lost cause in the Episcopal Church not
universally but
in the Episcopal Church the Episcopal
Church is lost so I would get out don't
bother with it you are not going to be
able to on your own drag the Episcopal
Church back into orthodoxy this is a day
it's been it's been a long drift over
many decades and now I would say the
it's the process is irreversible what
you're experiencing at your church this
is at every church every Episcopal
Church or the maybe there are a few
exceptions but I tend to doubt it and so
I would say find it find a new church
for sure as far as the pronoun thing
obviously as you as you know it's
completely stupid and there is no
support for it in the Bible whatsoever
the Bible is extremely clear in
referring to God with masculine pronouns
now we can have an interesting
discussion about what that means exactly
why is God referred to a masculine
presence what does it mean for God to be
quote unquote masculine and that's that
is a fascinating conversation that we
could talk about but as Christians we
have to start from the premise of
accepting what the Word of God says on
that subject because it is so
overwhelmingly clear and I mean that's
all there is to it alright we'll leave
it there thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed